well I think we have to ask ourselves
why you know why is the Great
resignation happening you know uh and um
a commentary about people getting you
know their government checks yes that's
a small percentage that's not the
majority you know somebody decides you
know what this is not for me I want to
follow my dreams those those are there
too but I don't think that is explains
the mass uh the mass Exodus
um I I think uh one of the things we're
not talking about that this is very much
an indictment against years and years
and years of of of uh substandard
corporate culture where for years and
years and years we you know companies
have
um taken advantage of or mistreated uh
Frontline workers they've paid them less
because they could because they needed
the money and they needed the job and
they could get away with it
um where corporate culture wasn't
necessarily great it was just fine like
how's your work it's fine like it's not
toxic like I'm getting yelled at every
day it's just fine and you know would I
like to quit I would like to quit but
the unknown is way scarier than the
devil I know and so we stayed put and
then covet happened and a lot of people
got furloughed or laid off or you know
or even just had the fear of losing
their jobs
um and they made it through okay and all
of a sudden the unknown became a lot
less scary and so faced with going to
work to a place that I know doesn't see
me as a human being they just see me as
a number to be calculated on a
spreadsheet and the unknown I'll take
the unknown and so I think this is as I
said before a huge indictment for
decades of companies uh not focusing on
strong corporate culture quite frankly
and not seeing their people as people
and so this is a correction we know
stock market Corrections happen when
they're grossly unbalanced well this is
a correction in the labor market because
it's been grossly unbalanced so you know
for those that underpay pay clearly is
is one of the things but I think also
um as you said before like when you join
our company we see you as a human being
we want to see you grow we want to see
you learn we want to put you on a path
to help you with to achieve what you
want to achieve and whether you stay
here for a short time or a long time we
want you to feel that the time you spent
with us was worth it and you're a better
version of yourself because you were
with us and I think companies have no
choice but to invest in their people to
invest in learning in leadership one of
the things that I find astonishing is
how little leadership education there is
in companies you know we give people
tons of training when they join the
company to teach them the platforms and
the products and we give them tons of
training when they're we give them you
know mentors and make an apprentice all
so that they can be good at their job
but as they make their way through the
organization we give them little to
nothing
we don't teach people listening skills
we don't teach people how to give and
receive feedback we don't teach people
how to have an effective confrontation
or an uncomfortable conversation you
know we don't teach those skills they
are just skills
um and when you wait many many years of
not doing that what you get is exactly
the situation we're in now it is worth
noting that the companies with very
strong corporate cultures who have been
investing in these things are suffering
a lot less yes they're still having
people leave to follow their dreams and
those things but we you know those are
positive
um but the ones who are uh you know
giving a certain finger as they're
walking out the door and saying I don't
need this
um those companies are suffering uh
those situations a lot less because
their people have gratitude